why that then
where are you now
fish at the first room
what are we going to do
yes is a beautiful day
uh the moods for uh the minimum hourly wage
we do not have a minimum hourly wage in the Netherlands
only a minimum monthly wage
and if all is well and the moods go well
then we have uh well
soon a minimum hourly wage in the Netherlands
and then we go four torque wrench
a very large majority in the first room has just
agreed to a minimum hourly wage
so it is arranged
we can go through this
and that means
with loads of people who are on minimum wage
they are going to fruit on it
that is really great news in these harsh times
very nice law and he is through
yes but bram becomes snacks